welcome back our next talk is by Ari
karchmer of BU to talk about new
approaches heuristic pack learning
versus PRS
o thank you um so this is new approaches
to your stick back learning versus prfs
and it's joint work with Marco carmacino
so this talk will be all about work with
one goal in mind and that's to prove an
equivalence between hardness of learning
and existence of cryptography
so what would this entail well we should
fix a model for Learning and the meaning
for cryptography so today will be about
Pac learning
um which is a famous model for machine
learning due to Valiants
and one-way functions which arguably
characterize the existence of
cryptography through many celebrated
equivalences and implications from shown
throughout the years
so what is it that I really want to
prove
um that's
that pack learning Boolean circuits is
hard it can only have one-way functions
exist
and um so what happens if you do this
well then uh you could
potentially if you wanted to rename
pestilian to Pacifica so why is that
um well you would have shown that if one
way functions don't exist then you've
got great worst case back wearing of
circus
so this world may be a lot less
pessimistic
so what about pack learning anyway so
we'll keep this somewhat informal but
concept class C is pack learnable if
there's an algorithm algorithm such that
for any Boolean Concept in the class any
example of distribution row over n Bits
um there's the algorithm the learner can
output a hypothesis H that approximates
the concept
over the example distribution with high
probability
and in this case what we do is we allow
the learner to interact with an oracle
this is a random example Oracle that
returns when invoked returns a random
end bit example with a label from f
and this algorithm would be considered
efficient if it runs in time polynomial
and n and one over Epsilon and Delta
one of our Epsilon 1 over Delta
so
um okay so so far it's been very hard to
get learning algorithms in the setting
besides perhaps some relatively simple
concept classes
for example free CNF or decisionless
but on the other hand there are several
interesting relaxations of this learning
model some in particular are membership
queries so in this case we would uh
replace this example Oracle instead with
direct access to the function so the
learner could submit some arbitrary
query and obtain the label
alternatively you could
use the distribution specific relaxation
where we would get rid of this for all
quantifier over distributions and
instead consider one fixed row
and then finally average case over
Concepts where you get rid of this for
all quantifier and consider some
distribution over C that
picks some function or concept f
so these relaxations have enabled some
progress and
um so for example it's been shown in
this model or related models that you
can learn uh random monotone dnfs
um
and uh
so this kind of prompts the question I
mean were these relaxations necessary
and if so uh can we at least benefit
from the hardness of the gold standard
double worst case pack winner
and um yeah so recently mikito nanoshima
Define like a good canonical formulation
of the distribution specific and average
case concept relaxation says the year
your Pac learning heuristic pack
learning and um so we'll frequently
State results in this model which is
nice because it's robust under some
natural variations and generalizes the
one of the original uh average case
models that's from Bloom first currents
and Lipton in 93 for average case
prediction problems
so what about
those equivalences between one-way
functions and other Primitives that I
was talking about so for example each of
these Primitives on the screen are known
to to be equivalent and they fall under
the class of minicrypt Primitives
and um but even Primitives are not on
the screen like for example public
encryption are uh even if we can't go
from one of these to public don't know
how to go from one of these to public
key encryption
uh public encryption implies one of my
functions so in that sense they're
required and um
so yeah that's why we're talking about
why my functions is characterizing
cryptography
specifically among these three
how do we get uh from all my functions
to prf so
I started in public outside 11 and Luby
showed how to construct prgs from any
one-way function and then ggm goldricer
goldblog or gold right goldbuster and
Macaulay introduce prfs and showed how
to construct them from prgs
and so these are celebrated equivalences
but um
maybe somewhat incidentally as
observed by Valiant it's actually gets
us halfway towards our goal
um so why is that well one way we can
now prove that when my functions imply
hardness of pack learning
you take you would take some of my
function map it to a prg and then a prf
and then just observe that a pack
rendering algorithm for for Boolean
circuits would
go a long way to distinguish the spirit
and then you could unwind these security
reductions and and invert the one by
function
so this uh by now is sometimes referred
to as the trivial Direction but you know
of course what it's really doing is
trivializing the direction
okay what about the other direction
um so here we want to construct a
one-way function from the hardness of
learning we're all we will almost always
think of this in the contrapositive
today
and it's been concerned considered since
at least the early 90s first by in
February 11 and also Bloom first
currents and Lipton
and in this direction there is much less
to say unless we at least significantly
relax the problem particularly we'll be
talking about the europac learning
setting so again here we will fix row to
be some distribution D and consider F to
be drawn from
concept distribution yeah mu
so the rest of the stock will be focused
about
making progress in this direction
there any questions so far
here so are you going to do what your
pack is yeah well we'll get there but um
well we won't get there fully actually
but it's so it's the Regular Pack
learning model
um but instead it's not we're not going
to have any for all launch fire over
example distributions that we want to
learn over I'm just going to fix it to
be some distribution D that's known to
the learner
and uh we're also going to sample the
function from a polynomial time sample
with distribution mu instead of um
considering all all functions at some
class so mu is over the constant Plus
kind of generally I think I'll even snap
project
So when you say hardness of learning in
that model the quantifiers there exists
a distribution D for which it's hard yes
so uh it would be for the specific yeah
so
if it's hard in your type model then
yeah
right so if there exists a distribution
D which for which heuristic packages are
then you're going to get one thing yeah
a natural pass so if you don't have time
to
algorithms functions
foreign
security
Let's do an example
um this is a good example and an always
conversation with an interesting fact
that it's uh due to now are in yoga on a
work that was
mostly about finding adversarial
examples to bloom filters but so what
they did is Define
a one-way function based on some
heuristic path learning problem and so
how does that one-way function look uh
take some some bits R and a bunch of
other inputs X1 through XM and it
outputs outputs X1 through XM and then
the evaluations of mu of R so that's uh
the concept named by R under the
machine that samples new and evaluated
on the input X1 and so these are all
then concatenated
so there are two uh observations to make
here first is that when you're trying to
invert this one-way function the
challenge that you get is uh distributed
the output here is distributed
identically to some Mis
direct product of samples uh taken from
from the random example Oracle
and then second
when you invert this what happens if you
can invert it you have access to some
Oracle that does so then that means you
get some coins R Prime which are not
necessarily the same as R but that must
agree
with the function that is named by R
Prime must agree with the function that
is named by R uh on at least those
endpoints
and so what that means is that you can
apply techniques there uh from learning
theory often named
by the name of Occam's razor or other
names like that and and then you can
show that if you take
as your as your hypothesis this uh this
function mu of R Prime then it's
approximating of our well
foreign
or other contemporary results all of
these share a kind of General Paradigm
in common where they try to encode a
learning problem into a
cryptographic or complexity primitive
and use the constructive contrapositive
proof to obtain a learning algorithm
so first on the screen here is this
influential work of cik where what they
what they took was a national property
or maybe even mcspnp and um showed that
out of this you can obtain a Pac
learning algorithm so this is worst case
but over the uniform distribution uh and
using membership queries so this is
under a couple of relaxations and
importantly this this actually worked
unconditionally for low circuit classes
like ac0 with Mod piggotts
then second we have Oliveira and
santanam who assumed an adversary to
non-uniformly generated trfs which is a
bit of a stronger assumption than we're
working with because we're going to just
assume uh adversaries to to uniform prfs
and they obtained a non-uniform pack
learning algorithm
uh that uses membership queries for for
polynomial size circuits
so then nanashima in 2021 this is the
same work that introduced the europac
model
um he showed how to take adversaries for
infinitely often cryptographic
Primitives like while my conscious prgs
and PRS and obtain uh distribution
specific Europe learning algorithm for
polynomial size circuits
and then finally
this is even more recently from hirahara
and nanoshima who assumed a bit of a
strong assumption basically that we live
in heuristica
and gave this uh gold standard pack
learner for for polynomial size circuits
so sorry I guess I I'm not sure what to
take away from that slide in terms of
what it's in terms of what results
you're going for so
I'll I'll next slide after the one I
just gave has some of our results but
this is an example of how to build a
one-way connection out of a hard
learning problem
um because what I showed you was that uh
based on one one learning problem in
this model where we fix the distribution
uniform here and drawn the concept from
mu you can then Define what the function
that if you can invert it if you have
access to an oracle that inverts it for
you then I can give you a program
analogy so how this differs from what
you want to do is you want to be able to
do this from any design yeah so that's
that's just the main that's the big goal
to be honest we're not no no but I was
trying to understand where this fits
into the foreign
foreign
work we're giving some improvements on a
lot of the results we've talked about so
far in a few directions
the first one is to consider a different
model of computation in this case
um parallel circuits so we're going to
be working in with NC surrogates
so in it
for this we're going to take an
adversary for a prf that's computable in
NC and give you a
you're a pack learning algorithm for NC
over the uniform distribution
and then second we're going to try to
achieve better uniformity and what I
mean by that is that instead of working
with just one specific
distribution over examples we're at
least going to be able to handle random
example distributions so the you can
think of this as like uh
take uh
using some distribution over circuits
that sample distributions
and so in that model we'll take the same
prf adversary for either NC or p over
poly and give you in this case a weak
double your pack learning algorithm for
NC or P slash poly
and then finally we're going to achieve
a better occurrence of security so on
the screen I've I've put up robustly
often prf so robust sets are a notion of
due to for now and santhan I'm um
actually we'll do something a little bit
stronger uh but not not quite
almost everywhere
um but even this is is a was a direction
that was highlighted by mikito nonashima
and his work as a it's a way to go
forward to to get the the true kind of
uh characterization of hessy line
any questions about those
um yeah and so so one thing that's still
open
is uh to improve this robust robustly
off empiric to to almost everywhere
and
really for today um I'm going to keep
talking about just this this first
result
um
one reason that I really like this
result is just the fact that you know
under the reasonable conjecture that P
is not equal to NC then you know you
could have potentially really strong
average case learning algorithms for NC
um in a way that coexists with with
one-way functions or minicrafts
not necessarily particularly likely but
but I think it's nice
so a few quick words for context
um our results are going to go for NC to
to go around this kind of bottleneck of
linear depth that's a rising from the
ggm construction so to do that we're
going to pull in a construction of
parallel prfs from now we're in Rangold
and 99 and this
is a great construction that uses as a
base object something called the pseudo
random synthesizer
and um
at least so far this kind of seems like
one of the only tools tools to do this
because um to measure open problem to
build a an ncprf from a one-way function
or even prg in NC so getting this
equivalence between these three
Primitives inside and see
yeah yeah well
foreign
yes that's right so
um I don't know exactly the statement
depending on the hardness but on my
function but I know that it's um under
some cases it's possible to build a prg
from a one with function and NC
but the big I think the bigger question
is prg to Pure advancing
so I think our results hint at an even
better goal um which is to basically try
to merge what was going on in cikkk 16
with what's going on and and
non-ashima's work in 2021
so what would that look like uh
specifically what I'm talking about is
trying to
uh live inside the the your Pac learning
setting even in the distribution
specific your PEC learning setting but
uh inside those low circuit classes as
ac0 with mod P gets
all right so as it started there were
there was a huge gap here because this
was only for uh polynomial size circuits
while this was scaling down tremendously
so to explain even more convincingly why
we would care about merging these things
we should introduce notion of weak prfs
um so I think this will also remain
informal but all I really need to say is
that uh weaker f is basically a prf that
only needs to be secure when the
adversary views random points on the
function
and so in this case because of this
relaxation
we'll often want to look for really low
circuit complexity even in classes that
are known not to admit full-blown TRS
so yeah why merch well the special
motivation would be to destroy weak PRS
in this class
there are
recent works that propose heuristic
constructions of ac0 mod P week graph so
in particular one due to oil couto
gilboa Shai coal and Shoal and um
so they're giving Euros to constructions
which just means that there's no
reduction to some super standard crypto
assumption and you can still prove
things about this uh which is for
example that the candidates are low bias
so they resist linear attacks or have
high rational degree so resist some
kinds of algebraic attacks
but I think you know at the minimum this
is in my view highly suggestive of the
fact that uh the natural property that
was used as kind of a pure F
distinguisher in the cakk work is um
you know uh as I understand it not not
re out uh ruled out by by these um
these classes of attacks
and so even if not even if you can't get
the full goal
um of getting rid of ac0 mod P week for
us there are interesting subclasses like
sparse F2 polynomials or even ac0 on top
of one layer of montugates
but you know actually as it turns out
even even this work has candidates in
both these classes
um
so it's no secret that cryptographers
are generally winning
um but you know I think at some point
they have to lose uh yeah you're afraid
what's the distribution over the concept
so in Europe like there's a distribution
over the concept class as well right
okay
distribution over Concepts in the class
so that's that's part of why it's a nice
um conical model
that that's in like the appendix of
they don't understand
it's a really nice property of the model
that stating that for human ordinances
devices are making these results
yeah
so the cikkk learning algorithm rules
out
a very strong pseudorandom functions in
ac0b
um but what I think you're saying is
because it uses membership queries it
doesn't rule out a strong week
strong in the in the quantitative sense
yeah that's exactly right so uh
but you know to both in the case of full
balance surrender function it says you
still could have um
address whether the membership queries
are really needed yeah so if they're
weak student functions in jc0p on the
other hand you get a hardness of
learning
yeah
of course correspond very naturally to
the average case learning algorithms
and the hardness is like two to the
square root of at least responsibly
numerals that's a projection it's okay
more questions
I mean so I think just to finish what
I'm saying is that the cryptographers
are winning but you know I'm not asking
you to break I love you either
so here's a statement of the result that
I'm now going to try to shed some light
on
um
but I'm going to generally describe this
results with the application of uh
repeat perhaps in mind but the
techniques are kind of interesting
because in some ways the traversal
around DGM seems to enable the other
kind of orthogonal looking directions
so
I'm not ashamed to say it if there is
one thing I want you to learn today it's
it's what's a pseudonym synthesizer
um so actually a quick intermission I
wanted to ask a very quick show of hands
who here has heard of a pseudonym
synthesizer
most of the cryptographers hands up a
lot of the complexity theorists know
complexity theorists should take home
what's a Superman synthesizer
so some basic facts about that I've put
up this kind of spectrum here
um One Way functions on on one end and
prfs on the other end somewhat in the
middle but kind of towards one-way
functions are our prgs and this is
giving some undefined notion of
complexity that I that I kind of made up
but
um
prg's in the middle a bit closer to
one-way functions
and weak prfs and PRS very tightly
related also in the middle but
surprisingly in my view closer to PRS
so um a little bit of justification for
that
uh
in some cases we can get one-way
functions to prgs with logarithmic flow
up in depth
um and from ggm we can get prgs to prfs
and in linear depth and from this work
from now we're in Gold we can get prfs
from PRS or weak prfs in logarithmic
depth so what that just means is that if
we have some PRS or weak prf in
uh Deputy then we can get a prf and
roughly depth D log n but one of the big
open questions is and this uh is
would go a ways to improving this
relationship a lot but how to build a
PRS efficiently uh for the prg
okay so student synthesizers actually
um it's pretty much just a prg but it's
special
it's a prg that almost it outputs almost
squared as many bits as its seat and it
stretches it in a very correlated way
so I'm going to
identify any function for Simplicity
that uh so that if it takes two and bit
inputs and outputs one and bit output
what we call the synthesizer you can
define a family of synthesizers but for
tag we could just think of this as a
fixed function
and so how do you define pseudonymous
you use the so-called combination
function
um
so we can take a look at this figure
the combination function
takes its input lists of n bit inputs
left and right and it takes uh the
output of the synthesizer
and um on
every combination from this list so
first you could take this yellow vector
and combine it with the blue vector and
get this place to Output in the green
square here at index one one of this
Matrix
and then similarly take the yellow and
combine it with red and this supposed to
be orange
uh
Fox here in the top right and so you
kind of get the picture this fills in
this Matrix of outputs of synthesizers
on on combinations
so we say that the synthesizer is
pseudorandom if when it's given random
left and right inputs lists of inputs
then the output this Matrix is
computationally indistinguishable from
from random
clear
so now we're in Ringgold in 1999 gave a
cons oops gave a construction of prfs
from PRS and log death
um so if you have a PRS in depth D then
you can get a prf in log def uh D log n
ope and this is a beautiful construction
that induces a very interesting subclass
of parallel circuits
so what is that what do those circuits
look like
um
they take at the bottom here all these
circles are key material and each of
these circles is two M bits and so the
first thing it does is it takes the
input which is a binary string in this
case it's an example of zero zero one
zero zero and it will use those bits to
select one of two circles so here the
first input zero so it selects the left
A1
and then the second zero selects the the
left A2 and and so on and so forth
and then that provides the inputs to a
first level of synthesizers
and then you kind of just iteratively
apply these synthesizers in in uh
recursive way uh all the way to the top
so why does it look like in this shape
the synthesizers we've just defined them
so that they take they always output
half as many bits as they took as input
so in log depth
um
you you get to the top which is just one
synthesizer outputting end bits
and I I wrote this is kind of pictured
in the case of synthesizer families
where at each level you could take a
random synthesizer from the family but
again for today we could just think of
this as the same synthesizer every time
so by now I think this should give you a
pretty clear map of what we want to do
and that's uh to use this play to lose
method to um take a PR s for prf
and so first we will encode a your pack
learning problem as a synthesizer and
then use the nr99 proof
to access this
this um circuit and turn the
distinguisher for that prf into a
distinguisher for the synthesizer which
in turn uh gives a distinguisher or even
predictor for the learning problem and
then from there we there are several
standard techniques we can use involving
constructing averaging and um
boosting or hardness amplification to
get a full the full type of learning
algorithm that we want
any questions about that map
so so what it what is this you're trying
to show that if you've got a hard
learning problem
then there's a pseudorandom function it
is
I've got a hard learning problem right
then I've got a certain function nnc
particular with logged up so it's a hard
learning problems in NC one
uh okay so why do you need the the other
steps are you saying like once you
encode the learning problem as a
synthesizer can you show the breaking
the synthesizer would be breaking the
learning would be breaking yeah so what
I mean now you know kind of proceed to
show you is kind of how to get a bit of
a more intricate distinguisher
prediction than that
takes a distinguisher for a synthesizer
so this is because what it would do
immediately is give you kind of a weak
learner yeah
you're kind of like convert this to a
stronger yeah so actually the conversion
to the strong Learners were not confused
today but really for the base of case
this first result I was talking about
specific distribution those techniques
are for standard I'm going to show you
um really just one technical obstacle
that we've got to get through so you
can't just plug it in you know once we
have a synthesizer then we get a
pseudorandom function because you're
actually going to be doing this
iteratively during the boosting and
you're going to need to like apply
something very extensively it depends on
the boosting I think in the uniform
specific case
you can just use harness amplification
because it's contained in at C it's not
that big of a problem
um but in the cases where you're
handling random
example distributions where these types
of techniques don't work because they're
inherently specific in the distribution
it's a little bit more complicated in
that case we say in deep learning I mean
you know
what one could you know imagine that way
it's trying to boost that but yeah
so
what's One technical obstacle here and
so I think what that is is that the PRS
just has it has so much correlation it's
not like a typical prg
um and that means that the
kind of classic distinguisher to
prediction Lemma it's not like yes it
and it turns out that it's a real
legitimate computational problem to
sample hybrids for this pyramids
but
you know if I may what ends up happening
is that you have to find a way to merge
reality which is information that comes
from the
example Oracle that you have access to
with a lot of counterfactual information
that's sampled kind of inside the
learner's head
so how do you encode a synthesizer
um again mu is a distribution over
Concepts let's say it requires M random
bits row is a distribution of our
examples requiring R random bits and
we'll assume that we have some
evaluation machine that takes this input
a concept F and an input X and outputs f
of x so the synthesizer will sample our
random Concepts and and random inputs
and then print all combinations of these
so this is using a combination operator
similar to the one that was defined for
the pseudonymous but actually this is
just inside the synthesizer so why did
we do that that's to keep the uh kind of
invocation of the nr99 code as simple as
possible and um
obtain something that takes two inputs
of the same size and outputs one output
of the same size
all right
I'll just draw up one more comment if um
you were you were here for makito then
she must talk yesterday he was talking
about
uh dualization of learn problems and
um so I think one thing you may notice
here is that this type of synthesizer in
a way seems tightly connected to that in
the sense that
you're kind of dualizing for free uh
here because what I mean by that is that
you're taking many representations of
Concepts and many representations of
inputs and and combining those but in
such a way where if you think of uh
maybe just the columns versus the rows
of the output of the combinations they
look like uh the jewels
of those um
problems
so in pictures in a picture this is what
it looks like but as I said when we
think about pseudonymous of the
synthesizer what we're actually looking
at is combinations of synthesizers so
we've got this block Matrix
interpretation here where each
um
each row is is uh labeled by by currency
sample Concepts and each column is
labeled by sets of coins to sample
inputs
foreign
there should be some colors here that
aren't showing up so if you want to
direct your attention to the screens or
just listen carefully for for these
indices
um but this gives a natural way of
defining sequences of hybrids
first thing you might do is um pick a
block Matrix but then this this outer
Matrix here in this case I've picked H22
and to the right of that so to speak
you'll fill it in with random bits to
the left of that it's uh honest
evaluation so the synthesizer and then
inside you'll do something similar so
this is kind of a folded
multi-dimensional hybrid thing where
again you'll pick an index and fill it
to the right with random bits and to the
left with honest evaluations of the
synthesis of it
so this is great but
one trouble is that you have not um
you know you have not figured out how to
incorporate actual information from uh
that's provided to you from the example
Oracle so what does that entail um
well first of all by picking this hybrid
in the example
we've kind of implicitly decided that
this is going to be the so-called guest
bit that's scrutinized by the
distinguisher so that means that
at the minimum you have to fill in the
challenge example in this case it's
written as Z in that column
okay and also by virtue of this being
the guest bit that means that example or
labels in this row need to come from
f-star which I've written to mean the
real concept that's housed inside the
example Oracle
so that's great inside H22 but this
introduces other correlations
so for example if you take a look at the
green the green highlighted squares
first start with YouTube on this isn't
the same row as
H which means that it needs to share the
same Concepts so in particular the third
row of u21 needs to also have
information saved from or taken from the
example Oracle why is that because the
third row here in H22 is uh real labels
from the example
on the other hand u12 is in the same
column as H22 so that means that it
needs to share the same examples and
even though we don't know the coins that
were used to sample Z for example that's
okay because we've kind of bypassed this
distribution by sampling it blindly from
the example article so we fill in the
same
yeah
example portions as kind of halfway
past the coins and halfway into the
computation of the synthesizer
and um then you know this introduces
more correlations that are kind of third
order at this point so the Red Blocks or
pink blocks u11 same
row as u12 so that means you need to use
the same Concepts but also it's the same
column as u21 so actually all the coins
have been determined for u11 already
um so as you're sampling everything else
you need to carefully keep track of of
all those those uh actually images of
coins and reuse them here
foreign
hopefully that gives you a quick idea of
that
um I think it's important now to see
so what is the actual hypothesis look
like that you output here this is a
picture of that
so
kind of hooks in an input at the top
here that goes in a z and you use a
bunch of random bits to sample a bunch
of counterpascial Concepts and data to
sample uh this particular row of H22
and then you're going to go through that
process of sampling this data structure
correctly which is combinations of the
synthesizer
and then you're going to hook that up to
a distinguisher for the
hypothesized distinguisher for the prf
and NC
so every time that wants to make a query
you kind of send that to the code
written into the reduction of nr99 and
use this data structure to answer it and
kind of proceed interactively until the
distinguisher is satisfied and then
you know one can argue that whatever the
distinguisher outputs is in some sense
evidence for the prediction and you can
get a weak learner out of this at least
any questions
so
it's also useful to kind of look at the
difference between this and crk because
again the goal is to see how far we'd
scale down
um
I think the first thing to observe is
that synthesizers are a bit like Nissan
Richardson designs so CK use Nissan word
just sent as the prg as a kind of viewed
it as a prf
um so why are they kind of similar well
you know in both cases you're applying a
fixed function to
uh subsets of the seed
in the way that I just showed you that
they all have pairwise intersection and
so the NW designs have much better
stretch so there's many more of these
sets and also they have smaller
intersection
but
you know using the synthesizer we were
able to get rid of the membership
queries
um but the drawback I guess is that the
the
nwprg is is just so directed that it
fits inside a to zero mod P
while the the code that we need to use
from the reduction of nr99 introduces
depth
logarithmic depth
so I'll just finish uh with some open
problems
um
I think the first thing is getting
really anything for the class of
circuits that's induced by the running
the NR transformation on for example
sparse polynomials
and
what we end up showing is that you know
any non-trivial distinguisher for for
this class of circuits implies a
non-trivial europaque learner for sparse
polynomials
so again that may be difficult but there
are plenty of subclasses that you could
look at
for example az0 composed with one layer
of montugates
um
there are weak to random functions
conjectured here so again may be pretty
difficult but I would say that even new
proofs of old results would be very
interesting and the reason for that is
that
uh so
as an example the work of cik
it's uh seems to not be able to scale
down further to ac0 and that's because
the designs cannot be computed in ac0
and so it's uh doesn't seem immediately
able to reprove some known learning
results
um whereas you know in this setting
we're not suffering from that uh
there's no immediate barrier that that
prevents scaling down further
so even if it's something that we know
doesn't contain mixed random functions
it may be interesting to get a learning
algorithm this way
and so I think the bottom line is just
that you know these are Frontier
learning classes and it's not totally
clear to me that these have been
attacked with concrete distinguishers to
to predictors
and then maybe a couple more open
questions that are uh just cryptographic
in nature so I don't think it's really
been considered much if PRS has uh can
live inside nc0
we don't suffer from the same problem as
weak giraffes which cannot be an integer
unconditionally
because they're they're kind of a hybrid
between prgs and weaker apps and in
particular such pure assets and nc0
would I think now imply optimal
constructions in terms of depth of prfs
and then finally along the send then
um constructing pure assets from prgs in
a more direct parallel Construction
and I think I'll stop there
how how should I interpret this in our
uh
bracket I saw yeah so in this notation
is supposed to mean uh
transforming synthesizer that's computed
xor those advanced search polynomials
into that kind of true love structure
okay thank you sir
what's like the smallest circuit class
you could
reasonably hoped for it was kind of fun
position
[Music]
like
maybe it could be stronger because it
has to be a long depth positions
I mean no I don't think it has to be so
you could think of trying to do some
kind of Circa depth reductions
again like when you put yourself up
against as far as polynomials or
generally Aces or like most Pig gets
you know at that point you'd have to
refute some conjectures
um so let's quickly got the conjectures
apply a possibility of a certain times
but you know if you restrict enough
like I said at some point
foreign